c'est sous haute sécurité que se sont
rendus ce lundi matin vers 9h30 au
collège du bois d'aulne à conflans
sainte honorine
le premier ministre jean castex et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer
pas de rentrée des classes pour les
élèves seuls les professeurs ont pu
discuter avec les deux ministres ainsi
que le maire de la ville laurent bros et
la rectrice charline à venelles deux
semaines après le meurtre de samuel
pâtit jean castex et jean michel
blanquer air se sont rendus par la suite
à l'école primaire voisine le claude en
eau toujours à conflans sainte honorine
pour observer la minute de silence
avec un peu de retard ils ont chanté
avec des élèves de cm2 la marseillaise à
la sortie des classes les élèves et
leurs parents continuer les échanges
on m'a parlé bas de samuel pâtit on a
travaillé dessus on parlait de la de la
liberté d'expression je pense que c'est
très très importante de leur expliquer
justement eux ils savent qu'ils peuvent
être manipulées par n'importe qui donc
c'est l'école qui doit expliquer les
valeurs tout le corps enseignant étaient
représentés et soutenu ce lundi matin
on est avec
l'équipe enseignante et l'équipe de
direction très très soudée aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le temps de l'hommage et
après le temps de l'hommage vient le
temps des actions concrètes le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros va
initier une concertation avec la
communauté éducative les associations de
prévention spécialisée et les
communautés religieuses
l'idée c'est vraiment que nous puissions
intervenir au coeur des partis et des
quartiers au plus près des familles pour
qu'on puisse les accompagner les aider
pour qu'on puisse écouter écouter ces
familles écouter ses élèves à conflans
sainte honorine un lieu sera également
dédiée à la mémoire de sa mère pattie